let's talk about the truth about men in
women's sports now listen the truth is
what we're talking about here is trans
women in athletics that's the issue the
right has made this into an issue and
they call it Boys in girls sports or men
in women's sports what we're talking
about is trans women born biologically
male in women's sports now the reason
I'm going to do this today
is I want to have one clip to point to
when people call in and call in and ask
me about this it's not a super
interesting issue to me because I don't
think it is even remotely a super
important issue but we will get to that
the right has been talking about this
endlessly Trump and others regularly get
Applause when they say we will ban men
from women's sports
[Applause]
okay here's just one example of trumpet
CPAC I could play a thousand of these
clips of different Republicans talking
about this but this is the gist of how
they discuss it I will revoke every
Biden policy promoting the chemical
castration and sexual mutilization
utilization how about you
and ask Congress to send me a bill
prohibiting child sexual mutilation in
all 50 states
that should be easy
and we will keep men out of women's
sports
big big big Applause line all right so
what is the deal with so-called men in
women's sports is it an issue sure it's
an issue think about it this way and
we're going to put up like a flow chart
here you've got all issues and then you
have specifically issues related to
gender and sexuality which are a
fraction of that and then within that
you know lgbtq you've got trans issues
within that that's a slice and then
within trans issues you know you you've
got
um mental health component you've got
um uh uh other uh Health elements like
for example
um you know hormone therapy and uh
gender affirmation all these okay and
then you've got like discrimination
related issues within trans issues
within gender and sexuality within all
issues and then within discrimination
related trans issues we have sports
issues and then under sports issues it's
trans women in sports issues and then
within that it's Sports where muscle
mass confers and Advantage issues so
let's not pretend that the issue is
bigger than it is okay so then they get
to usually a discussion about fairness
now when they talk about fairness
remember they don't care about trans men
in men's sports they also don't really
care about trans women in women's
leagues in chess or shooting
or archery or curling curling has men's
women's and co-ed or equestrian uh even
in golf I mean driving distance is
absolutely a factor in golf but like
even in golf this isn't a big issue
sailing which is already co-ed darts
bowling right so we're talking about
some sports we're talking about
basketball weight lifting wrestling
rugby track and field often comes up
swimming is one that's gotten a lot of
attention there are three or four
so-called solutions that are sometimes
mentioned when we talk about a trans
women in women's sports one view is Ban
trans women from women's sports it
raises the question of what do you do
with the one percent of folks who are
born intersex okay but you basically say
we're not going to allow trans women to
compete in women's leagues all right
second option allow trans women in
women's sports period or allow trans
women in women's sports if they have a
doctor
that signs off that they have
um you know achieved they've been on
hormone treatments long enough that a
doctor determines that there is no
advantage or you know we have to find
the right words but the idea is a doctor
signs off that this is an individual who
should be allowed to compete in women's
leagues okay fourth thing that's
mentioned is have a separate League or a
separate division specifically for trans
women
um and that's the way you deal with it
so let's first agree that we don't need
to worry about some sports as I already
mentioned we're really just concerned
with sports where this might be relevant
the first question is do trans women
actually have an advantage if you're
going to seriously discuss this you
first have to address the question do
trans women actually have an advantage
everyone assumes of course always in
every single one of these Sports the
real answer is sometimes and the reality
is that many trans women transition
early in adulthood sometimes they don't
undergo male puberty in the same way
that cisgender males do and end up being
indistinguishable from CIS women by any
casual Observer and there's not really a
concern there so with that group and
again we're subdividing subdividing to
really get to the core of this I don't
know that they
should be excluded from women's sports
league so if these early transition
trans women have no muscular Advantage
they may not have undergone male puberty
it seems they should be allowed to
participate without any issue based on
everything I've read
then there's the issue that a viewer
wrote to me about
basketball players are selected for
height
there are demographic groups that on
average are shorter they are already
underrepresented for example in
basketball so what about trans women who
are already smaller in stature due to
their genetics are they really a threat
to the Integrity of so-called women's
sports maybe that's another group that
should be allowed to participate without
much controversy so then we get to
what about trans women who have
undergone hormone therapy the data
suggests that after two years we're
talking about run let's talk about
running as a sport running after two
years of hormone therapy the average
Advantage for trans women in running is
12 now that's a bell curve and it would
overlap with the bell curve for
biologically born women 12 on average
means that many trans women after two
years of hormone therapy have no
advantage or actually have a
disadvantage if you understand how a
bell curve works and then of course
there would be some trans women who
after two years would have a bigger than
12 percent Advantage but the point here
is 12 is less than the variability
within the group of biologically born
women so that becomes a tough case to
also say ban all of them so the point
here is it's really easy and simple and
popular to the right and within the
culture War to say ban wet men in
women's sports if you actually want to
do the topic Justice
and talk about it like an adult and see
the nuance and the complexity of the
issue there are some real questions to
be figured out the the zoom out and
again this I I feel like this is the
most important part this is not the most
important issue now somebody will say
David my 14 year old little girl has
been training for softball for years and
they brought in a trans 14 year old girl
and uh that that trans girl hit a
thousand home runs and destroyed the
league okay let's figure that out let's
not pretend though that this is the
foremost issue facing America right now
that is worthy of the vitriol and the
hatred that's coming from the right and
also importantly let's not even pretend
that this is the biggest issue Under the
Umbrella of trans issues when we have
attempts to block gender affirming care
we have uh groups openly discriminating
we've got the bathroom stuff we've all
these different things
I don't even believe for a second that
trans women in women's sports is the
biggest trans issue today
never mind one of the biggest issues in
the country
if my daughter in you know 15 years
imagine that Baruch Hashem she ends up
being really good at soccer and all of a
sudden half of the other team is trans
women am I going to what am I going to
think about that I don't know what I'm
going to think about it but what I do
know is I'm not going to go around
looking to insult people or deny anybody
rights that's for sure and that's the
starting point where we should all start
from and then we can figure out what it
is that should be done let me know your
thoughts of course all of these
discussions will be on our YouTube
channel which you can subscribe to at
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show